thanks to Mack Weldon for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
imagine being a lawyer skimming through
old records for months working on a
strategy to free your client and this
MOU shows up to court like this you
can't fix stupid
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because I am outside of the
eagle's lair in a secret location that
may or may not be related to some skiing
and snowboarding that I am currently
doing and it's secret not because it's a
true secret but maybe because I don't
want people to judge me based on my
skiing and snowboarding skills but
because I am on location I asked you to
provide me with some great legal memes
and once again you guys did not
disappoint I have so many legal means to
get through we're gonna be laughing and
crying and everything in between so
without further ado let's dig in once
again to meme review meme review meme
review trademark of peopie all rights
reserved
alright so let's dig into our first mean
that you guys sent in the look you get
when opposing counsel is approaching the
well without permission so as you know
you are not allowed to enter the well
without permission the well is the
distance between counsel table and the
judge and if you are overly aggressive
about it the bailiff will tackle you
don't do it get permission first when
the only case you can find to cite is
from 1823 true story this happens all
the time and yeah we definitely feel
like we are in Victorian England here
with the powdered wigs and the
ridiculous ensembles the thing is the
older cases are easier facts and the
opinions that judge is right we're way
easier to understand 100 or 200 years
ago than they are now now if you get to
court and the appellate court writes a
decision it's on a very very marginal
issue it's gonna be really splitting
some fine hairs so often the really the
really old cases are often the best and
of course we lawyers feel like we are
characters in Amadeus okay when a first
year red axe discovery a blurred face
another blurred face and the woman whose
face was blurred before first year
associates are the worst when you
graduate from law school
you then often go to work for a big firm
and when that happens the thing that you
realize is law school didn't prepare you
for anything so you are really being an
apprentice for a law firm and guess what
you're gonna make some mistakes like
redacting things that are obvious and
then forgetting to redact the exact same
thing later on so yeah first years
definitely double check your redactions
when your client tells you he's done his
only oh this happened to me a couple of
days ago it wasn't a client so much as a
potential opposing party who had clearly
done some legal research on their own by
going on Google which is the equivalent
going on WebMD and then diagnosing
yourself with cancer do not do your own
legal research you will be wrong you
will look like an incredible idiot to
anyone that actually knows what they're
doing
friends don't let friends do their own
legal research when someone tells me
they got into law school my sympathies
oh man attorney problems really knocking
it out here law school can be a lot of
fun law school can also be very very
terrible and like the video that I did
last week about my crazy ex-girlfriend a
lot of people really really hate it and
they say don't be a lawyer I am not
necessarily one of those people some
people should not go to law school but
some people definitely should go to law
schools so if you go to law school you
have my sympathies but there are ways to
to get through it um yeah if you could
stop calling every other day for a case
update that'd be great so I think this
is about a client that wants too many
updates I don't really mind that the
clients need to be informed and frankly
it's the duty of the lawyer to reach out
to their client and give them updates so
often lawyers don't give updates nearly
enough but yeah they can they can
definitely ask for too many updates me
as a lawyer my client is innocent them
your client is on video dragging a
lifeless body into the woods I said what
I said you know it's not so much video
that is the thing that really kills
clients at least in a civil context that
definitely does happen in a criminal
context but in a civil context which is
most of what I do it's really the emails
the emails will kill you every single
time people don't understand that those
emails are go
to be used against you in a court of law
the lawyers are basically stuck with
arguing what we have to argue I said
what I said when the old dude asks if
you're the court reporter ooh that's bad
yeah law often can be an old boys club
and they will make all kinds of really
sexist remarks and it's a problem for
female young associates especially that
they get mistaken for court reporters or
staff or something else times will
change eventually and people will
understand that that's not appropriate
but it definitely happens the sales
contract had a few strings attached I
played with them for two hours
Oh kitty I don't think this needs any
excavation for me this is just a perfect
joke when you're a law student that
hasn't argued with anyone for a few
seconds I will argue with anyone about
anything okay yeah law students have a
well deserved reputation for arguing a
lot in fact there's actually a term for
that the person or people that have to
argue all the time they're called
Gunners and we hate them they just can't
shut up they have to have the last word
they have to ask questions yeah they
will argue about anything with anyone
they're terrible people
don't be a gunner civil law in a
nutshell general rule exception oh my
god oh that really hits home for example
we've talked about hearsay a lot on this
channel as you probably know there are
lots of hearsay exceptions and as you
probably know the exceptions to the
hearsay rule swallow the hearsay rule in
general most things that are considered
hearsay will come in like this dam the
dam is broken and all of that stuff is
coming in and frankly I don't think
that's the worst thing civil law
especially Civil Procedure man the
exceptions really preponderate over over
the general rule courtroom exchange of
the day doctor before you perform the
autopsy did you check for a pulse
no did you check for blood pressure no
did you check for breathing no so then
is it possible that the patient was
alive when you began the autopsy no how
can you be sure doctor because his brain
was sitting on my desk in a jar but
could the patient have still been
alive nevertheless yes it is possible
that he could have been alive in
practicing law I definitely have seen
this one before it's been floating
around the internet for a long time I
would love for someone to track down to
see if this is actually a real
deposition transcript it's just too good
to be true I know I really want it to be
true I kind of doubt that it is and also
I don't think that an autopsy would have
begun with a brain in a jar I think you
would have to perform the autopsy for
their brain to be removed if only there
was some sort of medical professional
that could let me know how autopsies are
done that would be really helpful in
this situation
hey legal eagle dr. Francis here now I'm
somewhat dubious about this particular
meme and I'd like to present the
following evidence for your
consideration you see an autopsy or
post-mortem normally begins after an
external examination of the body by
making a large incision from the neck
all the way down to the pelvic bone
sometimes it's y-shape starting at
either shoulder and meeting around the
Zippy sternum and again continuing down
to the pelvis at that point all the
internal organs of the chest and the
abdomen are removed and inspected only
at that point is the skull cavity opened
and the brain removed so I find it hard
to believe that the brain would have
been on the pathologist desk at the
start of the procedure hence I submit to
you thus that this joke is guilty of
medical meme malpractice thanks Rohan hi
learn something I think I found my new
lawyer just because you did it doesn't
mean you're guilty ha ha ha ha that's
actually true believe it or not so for
example let's say that a person kills
another person you would think that that
would be murder but let's say that they
acted in self-defense just because you
killed someone you did it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're guilty of
the crime of murder so yeah this lawyer
he knows what's up 0l people have to be
exaggerating about how miserable law
school is there's just no way it's as
bad as they say 1l I too was hustled
scammed bamboozled hoodwinked led astray
I wonder if that is in reference to the
fire festival that ja Rule did
cheese sandwich that was my news this is
done it's pretty much as bad as they say
it is doesn't mean that you can't have
fun you definitely will have fun but man
when elves are terrible oh yeah and and
zero ELLs are people that are accepted
to law school but haven't yet started
law school so yeah they definitely have
questions about Law School and it
definitely sounds bad and then you get
to law school and you find out it's
pretty friggin bad sprinkling your law
school essay with Latin legal
terminologies like non-st factum contra
preferential descend D this says ratio
descend deseed ND that's the new new one
by me own as a proof obiter dicta starry
decisis okay common misconception about
lawyers good lawyers really try to avoid
adding too much latin terminology and
really any kind of inside baseball legal
terminologies it's not persuasive
sometimes you have to do it but good
legal writers will do everything that
they can to avoid adding the kind of
language that isn't going to resonate
with most people so yeah law students
like to add that but good lawyers should
generally not if they can avoid it I am
a law student I have this weird
self-esteem issue where I hate myself
yet I still think I am better than
everyone else it's so true oh my god
it's so true we're really hating on law
students on this episode but I love it
when you get to law school everyone has
this impostor syndrome you are
questioning yourself you think that
you're not as smart as everybody else
and yet at the same time you really
can't help but have this superiority
complex over basically everybody else
and especially other grad students I
graduated first in my class from
Princeton I mean IQ 187 it's obviously
not warranted in most cases except for
business school students and management
students they're just the worst
basically Business School is two years
of keg parties and karaoke business
students
imagine being a lawyer skimming through
old records for months working on a
strategy to free your client and this mo
shows up to court like this you can't
fix stupid Clement Vallandigham a lawyer
who while trying to demonstrate how the
victim might have accidentally shot
himself shot himself and died he then
won the case tax bailed successfully you
know I have never heard of this I need
to go on Wikipedia and find out if this
is in fact true you can imagine that a
demonstrative that ends up killing the
lawyer who is using the demonstrative
that would be very powerful evidence I
would probably also vote to acquit if
the lawyer killed himself in the process
q insert lawyer jokes Ted lawyer good
outcome blah blah blah this is legal
memes we're not making lawyer jokes here
sure you have a lawyer but does your
lawyer have a lawyer I need to do more
better call Saul it's so good
usually the lawyers don't need their own
lawyer but with this presidential
administration the lawyers need lawyers
and those lawyers need lawyers let's
just say I know a guy who knows a guy
who knows another guy thank God the
Facebook lawyer is here oh god it's so
true I've run into so many people who
basically went to the Zuckerberg Law
School in Palo Alto I mean it's just
it's crazy if you do your own legal
research or you make legal arguments on
the internet and I'm reading them that's
basically what I assume you look like
all the time lawyer no guys you can't
show kids us baby Yoda is 50 so
technically he's 21 plus lawyer Oh
Keystone such terrible beer but great
means well done making factual findings
appellate courts deference to the trial
court ha ha ha ha ok this one probably
needs a little bit of explanation so the
trial court technically is the only
court that can take on new facts people
get this wrong all the time they say oh
I'm going to appeal something and then
think that they can add new facts on
appeal you can't the appellate court
will at least generally speaking is not
allowed to add new facts into the record
so the
guy that's looking away from deference
to the trial court the appellate court
is supposed to give deference to the
trial court's factual findings and yet
appellate courts will often find some
way of bringing up a new fact into the
record they shouldn't do it it's not
their job to do it it does definitely
happen this is one of the most inside
baseball legal memes and I love it big
law firms solo journey I just love the
idea of like a solo attorney out on a
paddleboard trying to use an umbrella to
win surf that's amazing the joke here as
you can well imagine is big firms have
all of the resources and the solo firms
have very few resources I would say that
in this day and age where even the
smallest attorney has access to legal
databases like LexisNexis or Westlaw the
disparity is not quite as big as it used
to be big firms can still throw tons of
people at a problem but the the solo
firms still have some advantages as well
so we're all getting by with our
umbrellas on a paddleboard get you where
you need to go can you guys please
recommend books that made you cry
introduction to property law yep that's
me I bet you're wondering how I got here
well the camera just froze over so I'm
gonna pick things up from the inside ah
the joys of modern technology and trying
to use them in the outdoors okay so
where did we leave off yes property law
so the thing about property law and why
it's reading that will make you cry is
that when you go to law school you are
required to take certain law school
classes and one of those is property law
and of all of the first year classes
that you take property law is probably
the one that is the most archaic and
arcane it's it's totally ridiculous you
have to learn this whole new vocabulary
I really did not like property
I really haven't used property that much
I use contracts all the time I use torts
all the time I use Krim law all the time
but I rarely actually use property and
its really antiquated and yeah it'll
make first-years cry for sure
all right arguing a motion to compel
discovery okay so the joke here is that
when you are arguing a motion to compel
discovery you're basically just throwing
accusations back and forth like two
spider-men who were you know pointing at
each other if you make an accusation
that the other side is not giving you
the documents that you want or they're
not giving you the depositions of the
witnesses that you want they're going to
go right back and they're gonna make the
same accusations at you this is very
very accurate it's a little too accurate
a little too close to home when opposing
counsel wins a discovery motion oh my
god oh that look at Nancy Pelosi's face
so the joke here is that when the other
side wins a discovery motion just like
the ones we just talked about where
you're arguing that they're not giving
you the documents or the the discovery
that you need and they win you give the
most insincere congratulations of all
times because you really don't like
opposing counsel and you really don't
want to give them the documents or you
want to get the documents from them and
maybe the judge is saying you can't get
them I I definitely feel Nancy Pelosi
I've lost my fair share of discovery
motions and it sucks every time okay
using the Blue Book guessing thing up my
citations home No so what you probably
don't know is that in law school and
really only law school you have this
thing called the Blue Book and it's a
it's a reference manual for citations in
the papers that you write in law school
you really don't use it as a practicing
attorney very much if at all but it
controls your life when you're in law
school there's these stupid citations
they're not like Chicago they're not
like APA Law School has their own stupid
citation system and yeah after a while
you get fed up with it and you just move
on because it's terrible so all those
law students out there know exactly what
the blue book is and they hate it
because it's stupid and I wish it would
die all right what have you wanted to
understand contracts but God said
Cardoso judge I just did an episode
featuring judge Cardozo the case of
what's in the box where judge Cardozo
who was
initially on the New York Court of
Appeals eventually went to the Supreme
Court that guy is a genius and that guy
writes some opinions that are really
really hard to understand so if you want
to understand contracts and you have a
Cardozo case good friggin luck where
were you the night of the murder me home
lawyer you weren't at Jason's me no
lawyer lmao dude everyone was there I'm
sorry you were there bro the party was I
don't know slapping is that what the
kids say these days party was slapping
you should have been there
did you hear everyone on Facebook just
graduated magna [ __ ] laude from Law
School
oh boy there is definitely a time of the
year when everyone graduates from law
school and they definitely announce on
all social media that they just
graduated from law school especially if
they graduated with honors and everybody
knows about it because they're telling
everyone all the time very true why yes
I totally spent three years in law
school took the bar exam and spent one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars just
so I could give you free legal advice oh
boy yeah so word to the wise for future
law graduates when you graduate from law
school you won't really know anything
about the law you won't know anything
about practicing law but that will not
stop all of your friends and family from
asking you for free legal advice if you
give free legal advice to someone they
effectively become your client that's
why you hear lawyers all the time myself
including saying that this is not legal
advice do not take this as legal advice
do not get free legal advice from a
YouTube attorney because if if I were to
purposefully and intentionally give you
legal advice that would make you my
client I met eclis bound to then
represent you and so that's why I try
not to do it and that is why all of you
new law graduates out there remember
that that is your best defense from
preventing a thousand people from being
your clients including friends and
family so remember friends don't let
friends give free legal advice
when you're at court and someone is
pissing off the judge before your case
brah I really feel this meme when you go
to court there's usually a long docket
there might be literally 20 cases in
front of the judge that morning usually
the the hearings are in the morning or
if you have a trial it's in the
afternoon and the judge will just want
to knock these out one after the other
and the thing is if the people ahead of
you are arguing they're going to piss
off the judge and they're going to make
your hearing particularly difficult so
yeah you just sit there in the gallery
amongst all the other people who are
waiting to have their cases heard and
you're just like come on let it go
stop drying up the judge I have this
like tiny thing that I need the judge to
rubber-stamp but stop screwing up my my
hearing and obviously when I go to court
I have to wear a suit and tie because
you have to look good when you're in
court but when I'm not in court I tend
to wear things that are a lot more
casual like the stuff that I'm wearing
right now which is why I'm so thrilled
that Mac Weldon is today's sponsor
because this shirt that I've been
wearing for this entire time both in the
snow and inside is a Mac Weldon polo
it's incredibly soft and incredibly
comfortable I've worn it for hours at a
time playing tennis it's great for
athletic and athleisure I love it to
death now I'm also wearing their
world-famous boxer briefs but obviously
I can't show you that but here is a
picture of me wearing those boxer briefs
it's definitely me it is not a model
it's not stock photography that's
clearly my body there in the background
I'm sorry that we couldn't show my face
in this picture but I assure you that's
definitely me
wearing those boxer briefs Mac Weldon is
a men's essential clothing company that
focuses on smart design and premium
fabrics and as I said if I'm not in
court I'm probably wearing something
like this much more casual much more
athletic I've tried their polos their
t-shirts their shorts and of course
their world-famous boxer briefs and if
you're watching this channel you're an
adult and you probably deserve to have
nice boxer briefs and I can tell you it
makes a world of difference
I ordered with my own money I had
multiple sizes shipped to me to trying
different sizes on and then I just
returned the ones that didn't fit me
right and kept the ones that fit
perfectly now if you would like to try
Mac Weldon and you'd like 20% off your
first order just go to Mac Weldon comm
slash legal eagle or use the promo code
legal eagle at
check out or you can click the link in
the description that I have put down
there in the doobly-doo so just click on
that link you go to Mack Weldon dot-com
slash legal eagle or use the promo code
legal eagle for 20% off your first order
and Mac Bolden's loyalty program can get
you 20% off free shipping and access to
new products and if you want to try
their famous boxer briefs and you decide
for any reason that you're not satisfied
you can just keep them and still get a
free refund because who wants to return
used underwear so again just click on
the link in the description clicking on
that link really helps out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis of
these ridiculous legal memes or do you
have another legal meme that you would
like me to review let me know in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here that has all of my other meme
reviews and my reactions to the things
on Reddit and Twitter and all the other
crazy legal issues that are happening on
social media so just click on this
playlist and I'll see you in court